[Music]
everyone Perry here with another
Collider interview right here in Park
City at the Kia's supper sweet we're
with the folks behind the movie the
night house which I had the pleasure of
seeing last night and I still think you
know like my whole body is shaking from
certain audio singers you're gonna get
to experience real soon first off huge
congratulations on the movie thank you
for being here today David I have to
start with you here
because a lot of folks out there do not
know what the night house is yet so I
have to ask you I'm very doing this over
and over can you give him the brief 101
yeah well I think on its surface is a
story about a recent widow who begins to
dig into the unexpected death of her
husband and uncover his dark secrets I
love how you did that without giving
like a single stitch of the story away
that was great Rebecca when you get a
script like this are you instantly
hooked and you're in or is there any
intimidation factor because I told you
before you're phenomenal in this movie
but this seems like a lot to me yeah it
was a lot I was definitely trepidatious
I think there was there's one scene at
the beginning with the with the parent
she's the characters the school teacher
and the parent comes in and when I read
that scene in the scripts I was pretty
much hooks just because I've realized at
that point that this character had a lot
of humor and was quite unusual for a
heroine in a ghost story and was also
had this sort of unusual beginning in
that she's extremely angry and wronged
and she's looking for something to kind
of explain how she's got to this and I
think that's a very different place for
a character in a horror movie to be and
I was instantly excited from that scene
and then I was pretty much like I'm on
board from that that scene is key to
getting you hooked I was actually gonna
ask you about the characters reactions
to everything cuz that's something that
kept me on my toes from start to finish
is you know I never knew whether she was
gonna snap back whether she was
terrified whether she was just
emotionally drained from the situation
so what kind of conversations did the
two of you have before jumping in
to a scene do you plan that out
specifically or is it any of you feeling
it in the moment I think we were winging
it just a bit on this one no I mean the
whole thing felt like a tightrope I mean
I I you know for me the character of
Beth is someone that while I relate in
some ways to what she's going through
and there are moments in the movie where
I was able to you know fill her shoes
and you know beep in perfect step with
her a lot of times she's you know
confrontational in a way or responding
to something in a way that she kind of
gets ahead of you you know she's kind of
out in front so sometimes the experience
of watching the movie is like less like
you're you're with her and more like
you're watching someone that you care
about kind of Teeter on the edge of a
cliff or something so in a large to a
large degree I just I we would go into
these scenes and Rebecca would have an
impulse for something and we would try
it when we get on camera and see where
it took us you know but I it felt I felt
like I was flying blind more than I have
on anything yeah you don't get that
sense when you're watching it very
random question but I have to ask what
are you drinking the entire time I
always get stressed out when I see
someone having to either drink or eat a
lot in the movie drinking from that
brandy boat oh yeah well I think it was
iced tea okay are you sick of iced tea
no yeah also haven't developed a taste
for brandy so I I mean I wanted to ask
you a little bit about playing a
character who is more so a presence in
the movie what what were kind of the
most challenging things about a role
like that I mean a lot of it was really
just really strange he was the strangest
things I've ever done as an actor so but
but David said it's like always
terrifying for a director to hear by the
way yeah but what David showed me this
like the thing that really sort of
clarified it and really helped
articulate what what he wanted in terms
of state and in tone which was the super
crazy weird Mark Twain claymation that
Google it's the creepiest thing it's
made for kids just google it
but it was a really strange state to
sort of live in and it was a really cool
challenge in that way because when else
am I ever gonna get to do that and
you're doing the voice work for the role
- actually it's my voice in whispers and
mine - yeah so it's like see like
something quick in my head you because
you pop up in a very pivotal moment in
the movie and you're a great source of
information also and I know that can be
a little challenging to deliver in a way
that feels really human - while getting
the points across so what was it like
doing some of those meteor dialogue
heavy scenes unexpected actually because
I really didn't know I mean you'd
started the shoot already and so I
arrived and was just totally taken by
what Rebecca was doing with the
character that actually a lot of it was
also reacting to her her kind of weird
trades and how she would ask certain
questions but also it was about maybe
not being that normal and not being that
real and so always kind of dipping in
and out of something that is very
realistic but also something that's also
kind of a bit odd but you can't quite
put your finger on it and David told me
at some point that my character might
not be real is like oh that's terrifying
and I'm now never gonna sleep again but
thank you and that did help a lot
something you brought up last night
before the movie even screen really got
in my head and I'm kind of curious what
you all think about it I excuse me if I
express this wrong but something like is
it scarier that the ghost could exist or
scary or the thought that maybe they
don't and there is nothing just where do
you guys fall on that what do you find
scarier do you believe ghosts are out
there all speech that I mean I think I
really think this is what's fascinating
about the film is because both things
can exist in whichever you personally
find scarier it's gonna work on either
level I haven't had any experiences of
ghosts so I don't necessarily think that
but one of my sort of primal fears is of
losing my mind so the idea that they
don't when you believe they do is
equally scary to me yeah I think the
seem for me that really maybe the the
the reason I knew that I had to make
this movie and I the thing that I look
forward to the most was the scene where
Beth kind of reveals her history and
talks a little bit on that topic about
what she experienced or maybe what she
had seen and I just found that
incredibly chilling and I guess for me I
don't know I don't really deal with it
much reading the script kind of brought
it back to the surface and and sort of
forced you to kind of think about the
afterlife and confront it in a way that
it does genuinely frightened me yeah
same boat yeah I mean ultimately like
I've had some weird experiences so so
I've so I can't say that and not tell me
a story well weird experience like of
something a presence like you know in a
situation that like made something
happen and I was really startled by it
and like oh that's odd and you know and
I think it's it's fair to say that that
nobody really knows like that our notion
of consciousness and like what we are
tapped into we don't really have any
clue right there's no working theory and
so like it's just a big question mark
and I think that's what makes the the
film really cool is because especially I
last night was my second time watching
the film and upon second viewing the
interpretations around that question
that that David poses at the beginning
of it is really fascinating and really
makes you start to put the puzzle
together in a much different way and
made it really engaging more so the
second time around David you've done so
many different forms of horror at this
point I'm curious is there any kind of
sub-genre within horror that you're
looking to tackle next
oh I mean I think after this I'd love to
do something that um maybe exists in a
solid finite reality
I think I think I've gotten a healthy
dose of the Surreal for now but yeah
maybe something a little more thriller
based slasher movie yes well I have to
let you go you have a lot of a lot of
press to do today for the night house
which guys keep an eye out for it I
still I can't quite shake it and now
based on this conversation I can't wait
to see it again even more huge
congratulations to you all thank you so
much for being here
big thanks to the Kia Telluride supper
suite for having us here do not leave
this interview without liking and
sharing it we're going to see you soon
with more interviews from Park City